c'est non non monsieur le procureur
général des proches de la république
déjà oui c'est l'heure du réquisitoire
ça va saigner
eh bien monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les jurés public rit rit
ouvrez les yeux ouvrez grand les yeux et
regarder avec moi la citoyenne fosse est
honteusement tapie au fond du box de
l'infamie exemple hagarde penaude moulu
blafarde des fêtes
humilié mais pas mal foutues quand même
ne luttons pas mesdames et messieurs les
jurés ne luttons pas sur ce blanc visage
bronzé tout linge et du perversité des
fleurs du mal cher à mallarmé
c'est vrai pas vérifié lors j'aurais
fait après rien n'est vrai en vous
bougies de faux seins tout est factice
soulève le tailleur chanel de
l'abjection ma publicité objections pape
soulève le tailleur machin de l'honnête
bourgeoise vous abriter le diable
brigitte fossey et ce sont deux lits
deux pieds fourchus qui se cache dans
leur modeste bottines de chez carbine
pourtant dieu mais ce gag à ce jour
glaude masques à gaz pourtant dieu
madame brigitte fossey vous aviez tout
pour faire une bourgeoise française
honnête
vous êtes issu d'une famille
d'industriels décidément c'est une manie
c'est faux c'est pas vrai ah oui si
couple et la samba sow et d'aujourd'hui
alors si c'est marqué dans le famille
d'industriels du nord non non non pas du
tout mon père était prof d'anglais et
d'allemand à l'école industrielle de
tout quoi
enfin vous étiez d'une bonne famille et
les bonnes fées se sont penchées sur
votre berceau pour y déposer les
offrandes cher à tous les braves gens
c'est à dire dieu l'amour et le pognon
mais par la suite vous avez été une
petite fille choyé délicatement élevé
dans le droit chemin le piano la danse
classique peu de flipper pratiquement
pas de vrie avant avant l'entrée en
sixième vous avez vous avez également
passé une partie de votre scolarité en
suisse ce qui vous donne ce goût étrange
venu d'ailleurs qu'on ne retrouve pas
par exemple chez josiane qui a passé
tout à la communale pour les mecs vous
avez même vous avez même suivi des cours
d'art dramatique
c'était pendant le tournage du grand
meaulnes serre si vous les aviez suivi
avant le tournage a été témoin tard dans
ce film mais enfin il reste mesdames et
messieurs les jurés que l'accusé a eu en
main toutes les chances du succès bon
chic bon genre et qu'elle les a tout
gâché us à malheureuse enfant que net
vous restez dans le droit chemin qui
vous aurait permis qui c'est de devenir
femme de deux procureurs peut-être dieu
nous parle dieu merci
toutes les femmes qui vivent au feu des
projecteurs non pas dans l'oeil votre
lubricité perverse tenait si le jury
veut bien me permettre une anecdote
personnelle de tout à l'heure avant de
franchir les grilles de notre
sympathique tribunal d'exception
j'ai rencontré notre cher petit mireille
d'avignon qui allait porter une galette
et un pot de beurre sont tentants et
bien mesdames et messieurs les jurés je
lai bien regarder au fond des yeux notre
petit mireille mathieu
croyez-moi nationale oui les croyez moi
au fond de ses yeux là on ne voit rien
de lubrique
quand on la regarde au fond des yeux la
petite mireille on y voit le fond de
l'estomac et rien donc
à président phocéen vous auriez pu nous
émouvoir
vous auriez pu nous toucher abjection
objections vous avez vous avez même si
nous toucher dans les valseuses
mais hélas vous avez le coeur sec pour
gilles potel vous n'aimez rien ni
personne
voilà un grand mot lâché il n'aimait
rien vous n'aimez pas voyez plutôt votre
collègue la douce marie christine
barrault elle au moins elle aime mouly
tu oublies tout je ne sais quoi ses
marques et partout sur les affiches
elle aime le savant des stars mais vous
non écoute trouvé ça drôle
vous ne songez qu'à provoquer les hommes
et comme des dizaines d'autres femmes
s'indigne vous ne pensez qu'à exhibé
hyproc hypocritement vos charmes
troubles sous de fausses robe de bure
après cela mesdames et messieurs les
jurés je vous le demande face à tant de
luxure offerte
comment en vouloir à l'aune est obsédé
sexuel qui succombent
nous en avons assez des femmes troubles
de la bardot anna huber en passant par
l'ats gianni de la lollobrigida à la
viti en passant par la lorraine avec mes
sabots
ce mot
bien mesdames et messieurs les jurés
j'en ai pratiquement terminée je vous
demanderais de ne pas vous laisser à
votre tour séduire par les charmes de
l'accusé cette femme le mérite en aucun
cas votre indulgence je propose qu'on
l'enferment dans une cellule pendant six
mois avec moi si possible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fait étonnant non
[Musique]